[Music]
there was a dramatization of the OJ
Simpson trial called the People vs OJ
Simpson and it was I really thought it
was fantastic one of the really nice
surprises was you had a cameo in it
because while the trial was going on you
were a big part of the media coverage
you were the media coverage for that
trial as we did it every night and so
they had me in five six scenes they had
you in five sixteens and you of course
they wanted it to look like you and your
studio 20 years ago 20 years ago built a
set probably spent more than CNN spent
right on the center right they got me a
wig they got you a wig to head so I had
more hair than I had you know I had no I
was gonna notice I was just checking it
out do you have that and I was like you
never had that much hair I did look at
that said that wig cost them they told
me $7,500
they got me two glasses I was wearing
they got a shirt almost like the one I
wore the tie they they found her tied it
was like the tie was wearing and but
look at that set it's much brighter than
they said I had yeah did it feel like
did you were you tempted at all to wear
the wig around for a while okay wait you
know what my wife said what try to keep
the wig keep the wig in you I said we do
facet it every day because it took them
20 minutes sure yeah put it takes a
while to put it on take it off but it
did look as sleep with it yeah sleeps
like a king yeah we'll get to your
product to your product Larry so oh your
wife said wear the wig that means you
know what I mean oh yeah yeah
yeah wear the wig wear the glasses okay
it's getting steamy in here
you